my friends what i just said  is absolutely gonna happen over the next  24 to 36 months and it's going to  revolutionize the music industry  if an emerging artist came to me that  mike boyd found that does music and so  gary what do i do in nft land i say  use nfts to become your label instead of  going and making a deal with a record  label because you want the upfront cash  why don't you make cover art of your new  mixtape your first album sell the cover  art in nft form to your fans and let  them get 20 of the royalties and you  keep 80  my friends what i just said is  absolutely going to happen over the next  24 to 36 months and it's going to  revolutionize the music industry between  streaming sound cloud spotify and  between tick-tock of discoverability  building community and demand having  distribution the nft is the last piece  it's the way to get the royalties in  place but it could be your fans that get  20  instead of your label getting eighty  percent